[Musica]
oggi parliamo di protezione come sempre
quando si parla di qualcosa è sempre
bene partire dal significato semantico
della parola
e allora se cerchiamo sul vocabolario
protezione troviamo l'azione del
proteggere da riparare cose e persone
allo scopo di difenderle da ciò che
potrebbe recare il loro darlo
una parola quindi che fa riferimento ai
sentimenti più profondi e nobili
dell'uomo se pensiamo quando si parla di
protezione materna che cosa c'è di più
profondo di più velo di più toccante
dell'amore di una madre per il proprio
figlio e quindi
dovremo presumere che tutti quanti
tendono al massimo della protezione per
se stessi e per le persone a cui a cui
si vuole bene nella realtà se andiamo a
vedere proprio il nostro paese l'italia
è il meno assicurato d'europa
confrontando i nostri numeri con i
numeri di paesi che sono con noi
confrontabili come la spagna o la
francia troviamo che in francia ad
esempio al netto delle coperture per le
polizze auto che sono obbligatorie
le famiglie e le imprese francesi
investono il 2,7 per cento del pil in
coperture assicurative
per la spagna a questo numero è il 2,3
per cento quindi un numero comunque
elevato in italia questo numero vale 1,1
per cento quindi una differenza espressa
in miliardi che vale circa un
investimento di 20 miliardi all'anno
quindi bisogna presumere allora che gli
italiani a minor rischio più di quanto
lo amano gli altri europei
no di certo non è così se andiamo a
vedere delle statistiche sulle paure
delle persone che abitano
italia troviamo che il 64 per cento
delle famiglie italiane ha un forte
timore su quanto e come sarà capace di
curare la salute propria e dei propri
figli troviamo che il 59 per cento della
popolazione
teme di non poter avere un'assistenza
adeguata in caso di non autosufficienza
troviamo che il 55 per cento della
popolazione a dei timori importanti per
quando finirà il lavoro di quello potrà
essere la propria pensione e la propria
capacità di aiutare i figli a trovare un
lavoro
quindi una situazione in cui ci sono
tante paure ma nella realtà non sono
misurate e quindi è difficile trovare da
soli una risposta qual è la risposta la
risposta è quella di accumulare
liquidità alla fine del 2021 le famiglie
italiane hanno accumulato 1.800 miliardi
sul conto corrente di liquidità quindi
non denaro investito ma liquidità
giacente su conto corrente perché come
si dice perché non si sa mai
e questo è un qualche cosa che
ulteriormente ci differenzia dagli altri
paesi ed è un qualche cosa che continua
a crescere anche quest'anno dallo scorso
anno 2021 è cresciuta del 6 per cento
rispetto all'anno precedente è una
scelta efficiente meno di certo non
esiste un modo peggiore per gestire in
maniera attiva ai propri risparmi
è una scelta efficace
ahimè nemmeno perché non avendo dato un
peso al rischio è difficile capire se si
sta accantonando troppo e quindi nella
realtà sprecando delle opportunità di
investire quel denaro o troppo poco e
quindi nel momento in cui il problema
arriverà quel denaro che abbiamo che
abbiamo messo da parte non è sufficiente
comunque un modello sostenibile nel
tempo la risposta è no anche in questo
caso è chiaro che è un modello che
prende le mosse da un sistema in
transizione è un sistema quello di oggi
che vede
ancora un modello di welfare pubblico
chiamiamolo welfare universale che però
sta lentamente e non tanto lentamente
cambiando
chi ha diciamo la mia età ho anche
qualche cosa di meno ha ben presente
nella sua cultura
elementi come il posto a tempo
indeterminato lavoro a tempo
indeterminato
come l'assistenza sanitaria gratuita
come la pensione come il tfr sono parole
che fanno parte del vissuto di tanti di
noi
di tanti ma non di tutti perché tante
persone al contrario stanno passando da
una situazione un po più protetta a una
situazione nella quale un evento
straordinario e sufficiente a mettere in
grave difficoltà quella famiglia abbiamo
parlato prima del della crescita delle
masse di liquidità sui conti correnti
quindi si risparmia di più
sembrerebbe un buon segno ma attenzione
il numero di famiglie che risparmiano
dal 20 al 21 è sceso dal 55 per cento al
48 per cento quindi vuol dire che un 7
per cento delle famiglie
in quell'anno non è riuscita a
risparmiare e quindi tendenzialmente
è andata ad accrescere il numero di
quelle famiglie che con una situazione
straordinaria possono trovarsi in grave
difficoltà questa situazione dicevo è
molto chiara per le persone più giovani
se parliamo con un millennio con nostra
figlia con un amico più giovane
loro hanno perfettamente chiaro in testa
il fatto che il lavoro a tempo
determinato
se arriverà arriverà con tanta fatica e
un po di fortuna
dopo tanti periodi di stage e di lavoro
del tempo determinato sanno che la
pensione sarà molto esigua se mai ci
sarà e sanno che
la cura gratuita della salute diventa
sempre meno gratuita perché lo strumento
del ticket è un elemento che
contribuisce a ribilanciare mettendolo
in carico alle famiglie parte delle
spese che sono legate al mantenimento
del sistema sanitario nazionale
però questa cosa sta diventando chiara
anche a una fascia della popolazione più
anziana
se prendiamo quella fascia chiamiamola
mezza via dai 30 35 anni fino ai 50
questa è una fascia che è partita ha
iniziato la propria la propria vita con
un modello di welfare chiaramente
disegnato e quindi è abituata comunque a
prevedere che questo modello ci sia e ha
investito e continua ad investire su
questo modello attraverso le tasse
che cosa succede vede che questo modello
sta cambiando perché i costi del ticket
sanitario continuano a crescere
continuano a estendersi su un numero di
patologie sempre maggiore a meno che non
si sia in una situazione di povertà
conclamata naturalmente ma non soltanto
le tutele per il singolo si stanno
riducendo
ma proprio la struttura il disegno del
sistema di welfare sta cambiando
l'abbiamo visto bene durante la pandemia
quando il sistema di medicina del
territorio di fatto si è dissolto che al
cittadino non è rimasto che fare ricorso
alle strutture di pronto soccorso
intasando le sappiamo bene creando quale
tipo di problemi
quindi ci troviamo in una situazione che
è ancora all'interno di un sistema di
welfare pubblico in riduzione in
contrazione
ma che ci dà sempre meno affidamento lo
stato mamma esiste sempre meno e quindi
dobbiamo passare da una situazione di
contesto esterno che mi dà sicurezza a
una situazione in cui e ciascuno di noi
che costruisce le sue proprie sicurezze
e la sua propria protezione
come fare be e complesso non è un
qualche cosa che per il quale basta
mettere da parte un po di soldi come
abbiamo visto non è neanche un qualche
cosa per cui
compra una polizza ogni tanto sulla base
di un intuizione o il suggerimento di un
amico ho bisogno di qualcosa di più
strutturato che mi aiuti prima di tutto
a pesare i miei rischi a capire quanto
pesano oggi i rischi che io corro e
quanto peseranno nel futuro perché
evidentemente io sto costruendo una
protezione che mi tuteli anche andando
verso il futuro e quindi ci sono diversi
modi per approcciare questo tipo di
problema
ognuno lo può fare come crede
a me è piaciuto immaginare due modelli
che ho chiamato l'incauto pentito e
sistematico ma sono due esempi ve li
propongo e poi tiriamo le somme alla
fine
l'incauto pentito è qualcuno che sta a
mezzavia come dicevo prima tra i 35 ei
50 anni e qualcuno che nella vita ha
fatto tutta una serie di cose però
sempre senza considerare la componente
della protezione al netto dell'acquisto
della polizza auto che sappiamo è
obbligatorio è quindi da quella non si
scappa
allora l'incauto pentito è un libero
professionista
ha un mutuo ha una compagna ha due figli
ea dei genitori dai quali accadeva
l'aumento dei costi della sua attività
la volatilità del suo reddito qualche
acciacco l'andare avanti dell'età i
figli che crescono insomma tutte queste
cose insieme
gli hanno fatto pensare che forse
sarebbe una cosa buona pensare di
costruirsi un po di protezione
però come fare non è semplice farlo da
solo
c'è bisogno di una guida c'è bisogno di
qualcuno come come virgilio che ci guida
in questa strada un po impervia
aiutandoci a capire il valore dei rischi
e aiutando anche a pesare in qualche
modo le paure che ciascuno di noi ha
e costruendo una soluzione che ottimizzi
in qualche modo il livello di protezione
che acquistiamo e quello che decidiamo
di tenere in auto assicurazione ce lo
proteggiamo da noi
i mezzi la modularità e che ottimizzi
ovviamente il costo complessivo e che
per di più ci aiuti nel futuro a far
evolvere questo meccanismo perché la
vita evolve e la protezione deve
evolvere con le fasi della vita
se poi questa guida questo virgilio ha
già con l'incauto pentito una relazione
forte di conoscenza di stima di fiducia
su altri ambiti finanziari in
particolare la gestione degli
investimenti in particolare della
gestione del debito ecco se questo è
vero questo semplifica le cose perché in
qualche maniera la gestione del rischio
e il terzo lato del triangolo del
welfare familiare
e quindi è chiaro che è più facile
introdurre anche gli argomenti di
protezione
nel momento in cui ci sono altri
elementi sul tavolo e soprattutto un
rapporto di stima e di fiducia
consolidato e questo è tanto più facile
se dall'altra parte c'è la tua banca
è tanto più facile
anche in funzione del numero di
occasioni di contatto che ci sono ne
abbiamo tante occasione di essere in
contatto con la nostra banca o in
contatto fisico in contatto digitale ma
comunque sono veramente tante le
opportunità ed è importante cogliere
alcune di queste anche quando non è
l'obiettivo per parlare di protezione
perché questo è uno degli elementi che
contribuisce a ridurre a mitigare in
maniera significativa la scarsa cultura
per la protezione che c'è in questo
paese
il sistematico è qualcuno
tendenzialmente una fascia d'età più
giovani
è un qualcuno che è appassionato
dell'online fa tutto online non riesce
proprio a capire come si possa non
comprare qualsiasi cosa online non non
appena un finanziamento on line è
chiaramente lavora in quel modo e vive
la sua vita privata in quel modo
e chiaro che introdurre un concetto di
protezione in un contesto così fluido
come questo è un po più complicato
eppure non è tanto diverso dalla logica
che abbiamo visto nell'incauto pentito
perché una cosa sicura entrambi non
cercano la protezione
il successo c'è quando è la protezione
che va da loro in forma diversa la guida
che porta la protezione nei ragionamenti
con
l'incauto pentito il web che porta alla
protezione dove bella porta all'ultimo
click del customer journey quando lui
sta comprando una bicicletta un viaggio
un finanziamento ma lo volete l'ultimo
click è destinato a dire vuoi proteggere
questa cosa che stai comprando con una
forma di protezione
pensiamo se io oggi compra online lo
skipass
ecco l'ultima cosa che mi viene chiesto
se io voglio comprare le rc dello
sciatore che protegge me se ne faccio
male ma protegge anche qualcun altro a
cui posso fare male io anche se ci va
bene
la guida in questo caso non è
la persona fisica il consulente il
virgilio dell'incauto pentito
la guida in questo caso sono le
informazioni che di volta in volta
di sistematico acquisisce sul web
costruendo in maniera progressiva
la propria cultura della protezione
anche lui
non insegue la protezione ma compra la
protezione quando la trova perché
cercava dell'altro
contrariamente invece
all'incauto pentito il sistematico
tendenzialmente avrà una maggiore
modularità nei propri acquisti
probabilmente un costo medio più basso
ma soprattutto il fatto di questa
cultura acquisita che tenderà a
considerare la componente della
protezione in tante delle azioni che lui
fa nel corso della sua vita
quindi l'incauto pentito e sistematico
sono due modelli come le possono
esistere al 300 non c'è il migliore il
peggiore sono tutti virtuosi nel momento
in cui
qualcuno aumenta il livello di
protezione per se stesso e per i propri
cari in questo senso quello che dobbiamo
essere certi
di riuscire a considerare due cose la
prima cosa ciò che noi vogliamo
proteggere noi stessi le persone
chiamiamo le cose che abbiamo costruito
i nostri sogni i nostri progetti i
nostri obiettivi da una parte e
dall'altra tenere presente il contesto
esterno che diventa sempre più
minaccioso da questo punto di vista che
è quello che crea
nuovi problemi e nuove sfide da superare
nuove ansie nuove paure nel momento in
cui noi riusciamo a tenere in equilibrio
queste due situazioni e riusciamo essere
sereni e nel farlo vuol dire che il
nostro livello di protezione è il
livello di protezione corretto se questo
non è vero devo cercare dell'altro per
rimettere in equilibrio due piatti della
bilancia
e del resto
nella vita il rischio è ineludibile ed è
anche parte se volete del divertimento
andré gide diceva che nessun uomo potrà
mai scoprire un nuovo oceano se non ha
il coraggio di perdere di vista la
spiaggia
e io aggiungo
è meglio però che una volta che hai
perso di vista la spiaggia se per caso
si sbaglia la lotta si sia sereni sul
fatto che ci sarà qualcuno che ci viene
ad aiutare
grazie